good morning believe nation today's
messages stay focused on your dream over
to you Russell Simmons the business plan
may not work out the way you wrote it
down there be some deviations there'll
be some roadblocks people start over
again and again and again on new ideas
but the person who stays focused on his
idea on his dream realizes history I've
never had a business that that didn't
hit the roadblocks every business from
my record business TV show runs house
runs house was turned down ten times and
we just kept pushing fat farm we had we
addressed it over and over and over
again fix you up later power I never
have an overnight success so you guys
know as entrepreneurs it's easy to get
discouraged and it's easy to lose focus
when you're not seeing the momentum that
you want when you're not making the
money that you want when you're not
getting the customers coming in when you
have those bills piling up when you've
got your friends and family telling you
that you're crazy for doing this when
you have that voice in the back of your
head saying am I really meant out to be
an entrepreneur right it's easy to lose
your focus and what's important that you
guys do is not not change the dream but
just change how you execute you're not
changing the what you're changing the
how because often the how was wrong from
the start you had the wrong plan and I
remember I spent three months an entire
summer in my first business just
planning planning planning planning I
wanted to have the perfect plan and then
as soon as I got out to market I
realized that my plan was wrong the
assumptions I made were wrong I kept my
dream in mind but the way to accomplish
that would change based on the reaction
I was getting from people and so keep
your dream in mind keep that as your
focus keep the wat there but change how
you get there because no matter how much
planning you do it's never gonna be
perfect you're gonna have to make
adjustments and that's part of the
process keep focusing on your dream
believe thank you guys so much for
watching my question of the day for you
today is I want to know what factors
stray you from your dream stray you from
keeping focus
leave it in the comments below I'm
curious to find out thanks again for
watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events presto